that argument that Labour keep making
that somehow we built an economy that
has only benefited the few take that
argument that Labour make and stick it
where the Sun don't shine so here's my
advice for you you've got other things
off in the next 11 days I say put them
off family weddings birthday parties DIY
they all this u-haul p they should all
be postponed I'm not gonna be doing any
of those things at the next 11 days
there's something a lot of talks about
you should be thank you for introducing
a really fair and sensible system it's
not something a traveling told before
but I love while unaccustomed
experiences you will just stop there and
then having no coalition ordeal no bank
with them we want to build a feat of
Scotland the SMP you want to rerun the
referendum well there was another
referendum I know that's not what this
election is about but you know Jim
Murphy and EDD Miliband and all these
politicians consistently connect
campaign and if the people of Scotland
used to make the voice haired by voting
SNP and frankly other politicians have
to respect that